china respeta la soberanía la
independencia y la integridad
territorial de todos los países lo ha
dicho hoy el Ministerio de exteriores
chino dando a entender que entre esos
países también se cuentan la repúblicas
que se independizaron de la extinta
unión soviética con esa rotundas
declaraciones china pretende acabar con
la tormenta diplomática que había
originado su embajador en Francia el
viernes cuando al ser preguntado por
crimea respondió que sase repúblicas
carecen de un estatus efectivo bajo el
derecho internacional ya que no hay
ningún acuerdo que lo sustente no está
claro si el embajador chino pensaba lo
que decía o sencillamente se expresó mal
sí que parece Claro que sus dudas No se
corresponden con la postura oficial
china sus declaraciones En todo caso
generaron una indignación comprensible
en letonia lituania y Estonia que
durante el fin de semana recordaron a
Beijing que fueron ocupadas ilegalmente
por la unión soviética y que esta mañana
han convocado a Los embajadores chi en
busca de respuestas lo que está claro es
que las relaciones entre China y las
tres repúblicas bálticas están teñidas
de desconfianza desde la invasión rusa a
Ucrania por los lazos firmes entre
Beijing y Moscú las tres repúblicas se
ausentaron el año pasado de un foro de
comercio que había organizado China para
los países de Europa del centro y del
este las relaciones son especialmente
tensas con lituania debido a los lazos
cada vez más firmes que tiene esta con
Taiwán